bueno pues se ha cundido la preocupación
precisamente por eso porque tanto
armenia como azerbaiyán tienen a
importantes potencias militares detrás
en el caso de armenia es el país más
pobre de los dos que se están
enfrentando pero tiene el apoyo tanto de
rusia que incluso tiene una base en su
territorio armenia además forma parte de
una alianza militar en la que está
incluida rusia por otro lado
azerbayán es un país más rico al cual
las inversiones petrolíferas le han
permitido tener un ejército muchísimo
más grande y tiene también el apoyo de
turquía que aspira a aumentar su
influencia en esa región ambos países
turquía y rusia han cooperado en los
últimos tiempos en el plano es siria a
pesar de estar apoyando a bandos
distintos ahora estos dos pequeños
países que vivieron su última escaramuza
de importancia en el año 2016 recordemos
con más de 100 muertos por los combates
tratan de atraerse a cada uno de sus
grandes socios
para no perder ni un metro en ese
disputado territorio de nagorno karabaj